أنت تعرف الكثير من الناس
أه يتساءلون عن ولاء المسلمين الذين
يعيشون في هذا البلد ، فمن
السهل جدًا أن يتم استهداف امرأة لديها وشاح
على الفور
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
[موسيقى]
لقد خضت تجربة رائعة لأول
مرة في حياتي  لقد بكيت دون أن
أرغب في البكاء ، لذا جاءت دموعي قبل شعوري
بها عندما رأيت تلك
الطائرة تصطدم
وأدركت
أنهم كانوا يفعلون ذلك باسم
دين
صدمني لأن معظم
أصدقائي كانوا مسلمين
[موسيقى].
كان له تأثير على
الدين نفسه وكل من
يمارس الإسلام ،
إنه أمر سهل وبسيط أن تكون المرأة التي لديها وشاح
على الفور مستهدفة ، ولهذا السبب من
المهم جدًا
قول القصص التي حدثت
حتى بالنسبة للرجال الذين يرون الرجال معهم
برفقتهم.  الاستحمام ليوم الجمعة
للصلاة أو استهدافهم بلحية طويلة على الفور ، كما تعلمون ،
العودة إلى المنزل كأول
شيء يخبرونك به أحيانًا
هو العودة إلى المنزل
ما هو موطن
أمريكا كان منزلي
[موسيقى]
الآن بعد 20 عامًا كما تعلم  كثير من
الناس
يشككون في ولاء المسلمين الذين يعيشون
في هذا البلد ،
لكن هناك شيء واحد أريد التأكيد عليه وهو أه
هناك الكثير من المسلمين
الذين
تقدموا أيضًا
للمساعدة في نواح كثيرة ، لقد
شعرت بالأسف لأفغانستان مع القوات الخاصة الأمريكية
وخدمت هذا البلد
وأنا مسلم فخور
وأيضًا
[موسيقى] أمريكي فخور ،
هناك مجموعة صغيرة من الأشخاص
منغلقين في الأذهان الذين لا يعلمون بما
يحدث ولكني أريد أن
أقول إن غالبية الناس
هنا في الولايات المتحدة هم
أنت  أعلم
قبولهم
أنهم كرماء للغاية كما
ترون ، لقد كنا هنا منذ الصباح الباكر
ولديك أشخاص من
خلفيات عرقية مختلفة
يأتون إلى هنا للتبرع بأشياء
للاجئين الأفغان
[موسيقى]
لدي حياتي هنا لدي أطفالي
نشأت معي
حقًا ليس لدي
أي تجربة تمييز ،
الحقيقة هي
طوال الوقت الذي كنت فيه هنا ، لقد
دعمت حقًا حتى عندما كنت في
المدينة ، لم أعاني من أي تمييز أو أي
تمييز ، كل ما كان يدعم
الناس يحبوننا
[الموسيقى]
حول ما إذا كان التمييز ضد
سكاننا قد زاد
أم لا أشعر أن كل شيء رائع
هذه المشكلة الأخرى ولكن
بصرف النظر تمامًا عن
التمييز أنا مسلم ، لذلك كبرت
واجهت نوعًا من التمييز
ولكني أشعر  كما هو الحال مع كبار السن ، وكلما زاد عدد
الأشخاص الملمين بالموقف الذي
بدأه الناس مثل
التعامل مع التمييز بشكل أقل قليلاً ،
لكن ذلك يعتمد أيضًا على المدينة التي
تعيش فيها والمدينة التي تعيش فيها
[الموسيقى] ،
من المهم جدًا
أن  إن تثقيف الناس في الواقع
يقتل
التعصب العنصري الذي يجعلك إنسانًا
كما لو كنت
تنزف من نفس اللون الذي
أنزفه ، وهذا ما يعلمك الدين
أنك أنا وأنت نحن
إخوة وأخوات.
نحن هنا
في نفس الأرض ، نحن على نفس الأرض التي
نمر بها نفس الأشياء التي
لا تختلف فيها مشاكل عائلتك عن مشاكل
عائلتي.
وشاح
لأنهم
يرتدون لحية طويلة
أو
لأنهم يأكلون بشكل مختلف أو أن
لون بشرتهم مختلف ،
فأنت لا تعرف من أين أتوا أو
ماذا يفعلون أو ما الذي في قلوبهم
[موسيقى]